[Música]
uau é realmente muita gente eu vou
confessar para vocês que eu já tinha
imaginado falando pra tanta gente assim
antes mas eu sempre achei que seria no
stand up comedy
dizem que eu sou boa para contar
histórias mas eu só fui entender o
verdadeiro valor da narrativa
quando eu fui estudar gênero e finanças
e eu vou explicar para vocês porque eu
sempre fui muito curiosa com as
profissões ocupadas majoritariamente por
homens com 14 anos eu descobri que
existiam colégios técnicos onde eu
poderia fazer um curso e conseguir o
primeiro emprego mais rápido
escolhi então fazer eletroeletrônica no
colégio técnico da unicamp
aqui mesmo em campinas éramos quatro
meninas e 36 meninos mas eu como vivia
muito bem com isso
até porque eu também reproduziu algumas
mensagens masculinas com os meus amigos
então eu estava sempre inserida no grupo
mais próximo do terceiro colegial eu
descobri que não gostava tanto assim de
eletrônica mas um amigo me falou sobre a
bolsa de valores e eu percebi que aquilo
poderia ser muito legal isso me acabou
me levando até a economia no ano de
cursinho eu fiz um curso que ensinava a
investir na bolsa de valores
e aquele curso me encantou me encantou
entender a relação entre economia real e
especulação economia real
aquela que faz subir o cresceu emprego
subiu crescer os preços no supermercado
ea relação dela com as bolsas de valores
não era para menos a gente estava em
2008 em plena crise financeira
depois de fazer um esforço pagar o
cursinho prestar o vestibular
entrei na usp que alegria
mal sabia eu que ia passar longos anos
lá
entendendo qual é como era a
universidade
logo que eu entrei eu decidi procurar
estágios e passei por alguns até chegar
na minha curiosidade predileta que era a
mesa de operações
esse lugar onde sempre vende ações para
os investidores e que a sala muito poder
e autoridade se vocês assistiram o lobo
de wall street
vocês sabem do que estou falando é já
tinham me falado que era muito masculina
esse ambiente
então eu me preparei pra entrevista como
quem vai para uma zona de guerra
tudo muito bem é informado decorado uma
postura assertiva direta e reta dessas
que são mais comparadas com posturas
masculinas
ao final da entrevista o entrevistador
me disse até que você foi bem para uma
mulher é muitas vezes ainda esse tipo de
interação aconteceria
a segunda vez foi bem próxima da
primeira
um mês e meio depois de ter entrado
nesse emprego e na verdade eu passei
nesse estágio o que significa que eu
estava muito bem posicionado entre
homens e mulheres mas essa frase me
marcou porque ela me mostrou que o
mercado olhava pra mim como se eu fosse
uma categoria diferente um mês e meio
depois eu precisei fazer uma operação é
difícil e quando eu consegui tive que
ouvir o meu chefe comentar pra outro
cara está gera nova ataque conseguiu é
mas ninguém sabe o que ela fez com o
corretor para conseguir assim mesmo
duplo sentido é muitas vezes ainda isso
aconteceria
mas essa esses dois episódios foram
suficientes pra me fazer acendeu uma
chama do questionamento por que isso
acontece
quais são as informações que eu
precisava e eu fui atrás de mais
informações
sabe onde a forbes fez um levantamento
das profissões mais sexistas dos estados
unidos
o caminhoneiro ficou em 10º lugar
enquanto agente financeiro em primeiro
sabia que vocês não sabiam é além disso
no nas certificações profissionais de
investimento no brasil os efeitos é uma
das melhores certificações do mundo
apenas 11% dos certificados vão para
mulheres
já em banco de investimento é a maioria
diz que tem ali em os 30% de mulheres no
seu quadro de funcionários
mas a maioria delas está concentrada em
áreas de rh secretariado e limpeza
enquanto que não passa de 10% o número
de mulheres nas áreas de negócio
eu decidi então entender melhor né que
depois de entender melhor um pouco as
estatísticas
eu fui eu que as pessoas diziam sobre
isso e geralmente ela ficar em coisas
simples como o é mas as mulheres
preferem outras carreiras o problema
delas ou então biologicamente as
mulheres são mais aptas para outras
profissões em busca de entender melhor e
correr desse tipo de expressão simplista
eu decidi começar uma pesquisa sobre
mulheres no mercado financeiro com
entrevistas em profundidade ea ideia era
entender como a narrativa dessas
mulheres e desses homens que entrevistei
se relacionavam com baixo percentual de
mulheres no mercado financeiro
ao longo das entrevistas a mulheres e
homens de diferentes posições idades
experiências demonstravam estereótipos
similares do que significava ser homem
ou mulher no mercado financeiro
para elas a mulher significava sempre
tem que carregar um marcador social
sobre o seu gênero em algum momento elas
seriam lembrados de que eram mulheres
seja numa investida sexual indesejado
quando um cliente em cochichou uma
entrevistada minha no re piauí disse
daqui você não faça me beijar
seja no dia seguinte ao descobrir que
esse cliente não ia mais fazer operações
financeiras com ela porque ela tinha
recusado
essa investida seja ainda na hora de
receber um bônus
pior mesmo tendo uma avaliação melhor
com a justificativa de que ficaria muito
estranho o resto da equipe
se uma mulher recebesse o maior bônus ou
ainda na hora de receber uma orientação
para contratar novos estagiários
não queremos mulherzinhas aqui dizendo
bem claro que era melhor privilegiá cué
currículos de meninos pra eles trabalhar
num lugar com poucas mulheres era quase
que natural afinal exigiam a mulher tem
as vozes dela a de solteira ea de casada
como se os homens não passassem pelas
mesmas falhas e eu pude entender pelas
entrevistas que o impacto de um filho um
casamento na vida de um homem era
praticamente zero
alguns diziam temos muitos pais aqui mas
nunca falamos sobre gravidez o que
mostra esse distanciamento é esse
assunto não me pertence mesmo eu tendo
filho para que falar sobre isso ainda
alguns chefs diriam mulheres ficam mais
preguiçosas depois que engravidam e
ainda esse tipo de estereótipo
apareceria mesmo nas relações entre pais
e filhos quando alguns homens pedem pra
sair mais cedo e levar o filho ao
trabalho eo chefe disse
onde está a sua esposa ela que deveria
levar é é difícil mas vocês não podem se
enganar
essas falas partem de homens e mulheres
os estereótipos de gênero não são contra
construídos no mundo maniqueísta de
homens contra mulheres
mas num mundo complexo e multifacetado
em que homens e mulheres aprendem
reproduzem mensagens sobre o que
significa ser homem e mulher a nossa
sociedade
é claro que a gente está em desvantagem
no mercado de trabalho nós ocupamos
apenas 16% dos cargos de ceo e apenas 25
por cento dos cargos gerenciais e as
pessoas às vezes argumento as mulheres
elas têm menos ambições que os jovens
bom a gente tem que fazer essa pergunta
se ela tem menos opções que os homens e
juntar com uma outra em qual contexto no
contexto em que as mulheres conseguem
dividir as tarefas domésticas por
exemplo elas tendem a buscar e conseguir
subir a cargos mais altos bem mais
rápido do que as que não conseguem isso
mostra que o problema não é a escolha
das mulheres ou a falta de ambição delas
mas as características da nossa
sociedade que permitem que essas
escolhas sejam mais fáceis ou mais
difíceis eu entendo que problemas
complexos não podem ser resolvidos com
soluções simples
por isso a gente precisa de muitas
iniciativas que caminho para um país
mais igualitário de 2013
fundei hoje coordenou com a ana e com a
sílvia janeiro o grupo de pesquisa em
gênero e raça sexualidade da fé da usp
o objetivo é pautar sistemas na maior
faculdade de economia administração e
contabilidade da américa latina
a minha pesquisa foi inclusive incubada
no grupo e como qualquer pesquisa e
iniciativa pioneira foi desacreditada né
e realmente não compraram a idéia de que
seria uma boa fazer uma pesquisa sobre
isso quando a gente estava bem no começo
a credibilidade só começou a aparecer
quando nossas pesquisas foram parar em
congressos internacionais
provando que o mundo dito civilizado já
tava falando sobre isso há bastante
tempo na academia
já em 2017
me juntei ao andré a dani e gustavo que
estão ali na platéia provavelmente é
tranqüila inclusive há inclusive é uma
plataforma onde as pessoas vão poder
avaliar o local que elas trabalham com
critérios de diversidade
o nosso objetivo é construir uma ponte
entre pessoas e suas vivências e as
empresas que acreditam
a diversidade é importante e acho que
não acreditam vão acabar percebendo que
é bastante importante
depois de cinco anos estudando e falando
sobre esse assunto eu percebi que uma
das uma das experiências que mais me
marcou nesse item todo não foi tanto a
criação do genéro o da inclusão mas as
coisas que eu vi no meu dia a dia
uma vez eu esperei um hostel num quarto
compartilhado e descobri que eu estava
sozinha com mais dois rapazes no quarto
num primeiro momento eu senti aquela
sensação estranha
um medo ao puxar assunto com eles e eles
conversando comigo decidir comer uma
pizza com eles e entender melhor de onde
eles viu nesse jantar
surgiram várias frases muito
estereotipada da mulher com tatuagem
geralmente têm fama né
eles falaram quando viram a tatuagem no
meu pulso ou ainda na hora que eu quis
dividir a conta
meu pai me ensinou que sempre que eu
saio com alguma garota eu tenho que
pagar a conta e por fim como estava no
rio de janeiro
a menina na rua de shortinho curto quer
chamar atenção eu percebi que eu devia
falar alguma coisa e eu comecei a
explicar um outro ponto de vista o
primeiro tatuagem não é indicativo de
índole mulheres também querem dividir a
conta
elas também querem se sentir capazes de
fazer isso e por fim a escolha da roupa
envolve mais fatores do que apenas o
desejo masculino a gente pode estar tipo
com calor mesmo sob é expressão de
incredulidade e surpresa apareceu não
gosto desses dois rapazes mas ao mesmo
tempo eu via uma vontade genuína de
entender por que eu pensava tão
diferente
depois de duas semanas eu voltei pra
casa e recebi uma mensagem de um deles
falando que ele tinha decidido
não mexer mais com mulheres na rua
[Música]
aquilo pra mim e pra muita gente pode
soar qual ele não fez mais nada que a
obrigação dele né e racionalmente eu
concordo com esse ranking com essa frase
porém emocionalmente eu sei que é muito
difícil mudar hábitos tão enraizado na
nossa sociedade e que talvez quando as
pessoas pensam e elas estão na cabeça
delas com aquela idéia de politicamente
correto
elas pensam em regras elas pensam em
proibições quando na verdade a gente
está falando de uma mudança que acontece
porque as pessoas passam a não vê mais
sentido naquelas ações é isso que
importa não é mais sentido em mexer com
mulheres na rua porque agora você
entende qual o impacto disso
essa experiência me fez perceber que a
gente tem um potencial imenso que a
gente nem percebe que a gente pode como
um formigueiro e onde as formiguinhas
passam as informações umas para as
outras
as informações que precisam ser passadas
a gente pode levar um pouco de
esclarecimento e igualdade de gênero o
nosso dia a dia
isso me faz pensar na escala disso um
evento hunted x utah e de che na chique
a 800 pessoas pode ter um impacto bacana
vocês estão me ouvindo aqui e uma
parcela talvez ou todos espero que saiam
pensando sobre isso
um vídeo na internet a milhares de
pessoas assistirem pode ter um impacto
ainda mais abrangente mas milhões de
pessoas todos os dias no brasil inteiro
intervindo quando sentem que precisam e
elas sentem que precisam mas às vezes
elas têm medo às vezes elas não querem
perder a sensação de pertencimento
eu descobri que a gente pode ter um
impacto muito maior e eu aposto que
vocês ao entrarem aqui não sabiam que
poderiam ser ferramentas alta
notificados para a igualdade de gênero
mas eu vim aqui pra ligar o botão e tá
valendo
[Música]
[Aplausos]